welcome everybody to another special
episode of the into the impossible
podcast featuring today's guest ben
shapiro
now before you hit unsubscribe unfollow
and send me a poisonous pen message
please note that this conversation like
all my conversations with nothing
chomsky and larry tribe and eric topal
as well as with ben and his cohorts at
the daily wire and elsewhere is
non-political i don't get into politics
i don't think politics is particularly
interesting i've never had a desire to
be a politician or to target them i
think they do a great job i've hosted
the mayor of san diego
and i've hosted
other people but as always to look at
their non-political aspects of their
life because i think that's more
interesting as a scientist so today we
got into many many things you won't
believe it when we got into
ben's beliefs or lack thereof about
space travel and even on
extraterrestrial intelligence so you
won't want to miss that or any other
portion of this conversation trust me i
think you'll be glad you came along for
the ride and now sit back and enjoy this
wide-ranging interview with none other
than ben shapiro
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
welcome everybody to what will surely be
one of my many great plunges and
subscriber counts as i bring on very
rarely uh political figures but as i
always say
astronomy i got into it because there
are no republican constellations there
are no democratic asteroids uh and i
like a politics-free zone so actually
today we're going to talk with my guest
some say where we we look alike we were
separated at birth i'm sorry to hear
tell you that ben uh we're talking with
ben shapiro proprietor editor emeritus
the daily wire proprietor of the ben
shapiro show and ben how are you doing
this fine season
you know i'm i'm hanging in there but
i'm not in california like you so better
than you
well you're welcome back anytime your
your money and your presence as well
back anytime uh so we're going to talk
about a lot of things today but i want
to let you know this is our special erev
pre yom kippur special we did one last
year at this time and this one will be
out on the eve of the holiest day of the
year which you told me last year is your
favorite day on the calendar is that
still true ben that young kippur is your
favorite day on the calendar you know
it's one of those things where
philosophically yes and then in practice
no you know
i'm not a big fan of fasting i do like
food but uh the in in theory yeah i mean
the idea that you get to have your sins
relieved by god that you get to face up
to those and spend all day you know
dealing with existential questions is
really kind of an amazing thing so
philosophically yes um but about 11
o'clock in the morning when i haven't
had anything to eat or drink and it's
only been you know 12 hours or 14 hours
and now i've got another 10 hours to go
about that time i start to have doubts
that's right if you like fasting that
much you can do it for me or you know i
can recommend a colonoscopy prep that
that might be more oh man some gedalia
and then this one it's like two and two
in three weeks it's just it's good times
well we're gonna talk about judaism
because uh your latest book uh which
which is your your your sixth in one
year uh is called the authoritarian
moment and i can judge um holding it up
to the camera now i got an advanced
coffee thank you very much to emma and
all your producers over there uh but i
also got the real copy and the reason
was i wanted to ask you and play a
favorite game the game that we're never
supposed to do in life as authors judge
a book by its cover so ben rumor has it
uh that the book is partially inspired
by george orwell who we talked about
last year you remember we talked about
animal farm and whether you'd trade your
beautiful tail as as benjamin the donkey
did uh for a shorter tale and not have
to have the flies uh tell me what is the
inspiration for this title this covered
design uh where'd you come up with it
what's the uh backstory behind it so the
authoritarian moment the title just came
up because i i was thinking about the uh
the title of the authoritarian mind by
theodor ordono uh it was probably the
the sort of basis for it so there was an
idea by theodore ordono as a philosopher
mid 20th century who argued that
basically there was a certain mindset
that tended toward the authoritarian it
turns out that that his description of
that mindset was not particularly
accurate but there are other
sociologists who came around later who
had sort of a slightly more uh accurate
description of that but it seemed to me
that everybody these days is calling
themselves authoritarian and so i
thought that it would be worthwhile
examining you know sort of where the
threats to freedom lie and obviously
look i'm a conservative so i think the
there are certainly people on the right
for authoritarian but the the threats as
the subtitle suggests uh are
predominantly institutionally from the
left at this point so i'm not going to
pretend that the book is a bipartisan
examination into authoritarianism it
certainly is not um and uh the the jack
boot uh on the front is obviously
supposed to be reminiscent of that sort
of 1984 imagery that there is the the
boot treading on the human face forever
and i think that a lot of people
actually this is bipartisan i think a
lot of people uh in in all facets of
life at this point do feel as though
there are other people who are coming
for them because of their opinion that's
a really dangerous thing
yeah it certainly is and uh the you know
i always have this this paradox when i
read your books because you know they're
they're
intricately researched they're uh
they're decisively argued
and uh each one the footnotes alone
could be a phd thesis uh here at the
university of california or elsewhere
and so it is extremely thoroughly
researched um and yet i always have this
dichotomy because i always want to ask
the questions my audience would want to
know
besides why are you having your younger
more attractive brother on
and that is
and that is you know really to do with
um the fact that you and i share a
religion uh you are uh orthodox and
orthodoxy as i take it uh we are
supposed to have a king we are supposed
to have a king in heaven we're supposed
to have an authority above us uh that we
look up to and maybe it's that there's
only one but um how do you resolve this
paradox that you submit willingly to the
authority of god uh and do so happily i
i underst you serve god with joy right
so how do you reconcile these two
dichotomy why don't you serve uh you
know uh gavin newsom well you're not
here to serve japanese but why don't you
serve you know uh donald trump or or joe
biden with with authority because look
this is the will and we believe also
that god we pray for joe biden every
every week of of of the year right in
synagogue so anyway how do you reconcile
these two sides the authorities
that you submit to and then the
politicians that you refuse to submit so
obviously i think the divine authority
predates any authority to man and there
is this belief even in the bible
obviously when it talks about davidic
kingship uh obviously in the book of
deuteronomy when it talks about you're
going to have a king it says you're
going to regret having a king and not
only that the king is supposed to write
his own torah scroll because he's
supposed to be reminded of his moral
obligations throughout the books of the
prophets
the king is constantly being remanded by
his reprimanded rather by
various prophets right david himself is
reprimanded uh by nathan uh saul is
represented reprimanded by samuel
there is this sort of check and balance
system even with regard to kingship
which is the most rudimentary form of
top-down rule there's this belief that
the king is supposed to be subjected to
certain higher moral standards now the
belief that you ought to be you know
subject to a god in heaven also relies
on your willingness to submit to a
system of thought and what i mean by
that is that they're very there are a
lot of i'd say differing strains even
within judaism as to who you listen to
and why you listen to them i tend to be
much more my my monadian in my approach
so maimonides was very aristotelian in
his approach to religion it was his
belief that the commandments did have a
rationale behind them that could be
understood by human reason even if we
hadn't actually figured all of them out
yet
and so there was a real natural law
component that's what monitors was
talking about that really mirrors sort
of the optimistic view of thomas aquinas
at the same time in the christian world
and so it makes it a lot easier to say
listen i'm i agree with the the
authority of the bible but i also agree
with the authority of the bible because
it tends to reflect the the demands of
the real world and reason interacting
with those demands and so you know
you don't have to i think there's a
vision of religion that religion is
basically you throw out your individual
human reason in favor of people telling
you what to do
and the maimonides approach says that's
not really the case which is why
religion and practice of religion
particularly in judaism was a common law
sort of practice that has evolved pretty
radically over time i mean there are
famous sections of the talmud where
there's uh the maybe the most famous
section in all the talmud there's one
section where there's a rabbi who goes
up against a majority of his fellows in
the study house on a particular issue
and he's obviously right and he says he
calls on heaven he calls on the walls of
the of the bait midrash of the um the
place that they're learning to lean if
he is right he calls on the river to
reverse itself if he's right it does he
calls on the the uh a voice to come down
from heaven if he's right and
all of these things happen and then one
of the other rabbis says right but
none of those are authorities right we
don't rely on the walls of debate
midrash to determine whether a right or
a river or even a voice from heaven you
know it's left in our hands right which
is some of the verbiage in deuteronomy
as well is that it's not in heaven it's
here for you and so that means the
interaction of the human the interaction
of reason and revelation lies at the
core of my faith so if you get
completely rid of reason then i think
you end up with theocracy and if you get
completely rid of revelation i think
that you end up at sort of a nietzschean
nietzsche
nihilism what do you say to those who
you know witnessing that tragedy and the
um you know
man-made tragedy in afghanistan say well
you know it's it's great to speak about
these as eighth century you know
barbarians and thugs
but uh but wouldn't you like that i mean
wouldn't you like not an authoritarian
theocracy but the rules of judaism are
pretty proscribed as you say as you talk
about um you know would you submit to uh
if we could somehow revivify you know
all the conditions needed to restore
messianic times etc would you then
submit to an authoritarian to a
government not not just to god obviously
but to you know to a basically
semi-theocratic form of worship of
course you you would believe it's
benevolent and as many would would you
submit to that i mean is that something
you would look forward to let me put it
that way uh i mean i think that to get
into sort of the halachic details of you
know what messianic kingship would look
like uh is probably beyond the scope
what we're talking about suffice it to
say that messianic kingship even even
divided kingship the amount of
centralized authority that was actually
brought to bear to actually enforce a
lot of the laws around the books is
pretty limited which is why a lot of the
punishments even in the bible itself uh
punishment is for example
ex-communication right
you're cut off right social basically
social uh
refusal um or you have a situation where
we'll say that your line is cut off
which is really between you and god it
really isn't between you and the
compulsive government and what the
government can compel you to do
there's sort of a lot of commentaries
about what the government could allow
you but listen i'm not a fan of kingship
i mean i make this pretty clear
in and by the way i don't think samuel
was a fan of kingship the notion uh that
that the only way this can be done uh is
through uh a monarchy uh you know there
are a lot of forms of monarchy right i
mean there's a there's a british foreign
monarchy where the king doesn't have
ultimate authority uh and then there is
the you know theocratic monarchy where
the king has all authority so i think
that these are i'm again i'll rely on
ron bomb here i'll rely on my mondays
and i'll say that when the messiah comes
i guess we'll discuss it um but you know
the the my ideal form of government does
not involve one person at the top of a
government telling everybody else what
to do without any check or balance and i
don't think the taurus does either
actually right
well i'll just let you know uh i get
dibs on the messiah after he's guessed
on your show but
um i had on recently uh dr eric topal
america's doctor i think if if it's not
uh the first lady uh i wanted to ask you
you know he was you know kind of uh very
very uh of two minds that the government
has a very strong place and in fact you
know he advocated famously for you know
the withholding of the release of the of
the pfizer and other vaccine trials but
he's obviously you know he said to me
he's not in favor of lying to the public
to even to advance a good goal in other
words
have more mammograms you shouldn't
overstate the the amount of cancer risk
for example uh and yet i see you as a
very early vaccine advocate uh you know
that was uh very clear that was actually
a very very important i think a moral
lesson to many people that follow you um
so how do you know what's the rubric
speaking as a professor what's a ruben
how do you know when to trust a a
governmental uh edict uh a decree and to
submit to it because i think we we have
to submit to it at some level i think
victor frankl said
there should be a west coast statue of
responsibility not just the statue of
liberty so how do you know what's the
rubric to know when a government edict
is good or not
i mean they have to actually show you
the evidence and uh this is i think my
problem with the public health
bureaucracy throughout this pandemic is
that
you had i mean dr apache has admitted
that not only did he not show people the
evidence that he was effectively lying
to the american public repeatedly to
achieve his goals he did that on hurt
immunity where he said well i i thought
that the american public was willing to
withstand this level of herd immunity so
i said that percentage then i shifted
the percentage he did it on masks early
on instead of saying that masking is
effective and then saying but we need to
make sure that our health providers have
it first instead of doing that and
asking for some shared sacrifice he
instead said that nobody needs a mask he
did it with regard to masking with
regard to the vaccine so post-vaccine
but before delta he was like well you
definitely have to mask after you've had
the vaccine and then two weeks later he
shifted it
and we heard from public health
officials we're not fouchy in the middle
of the pandemic repeatedly that if you
were out protesting against lockdown
this was very bad and spread the virus
but if you're out protesting george
floyd this is very good and was it was
necessary because racism was a public
health crisis and so when you have
people saying that kind of stuff i think
it's very difficult to create the sort
of institutional trust that's necessary
to call upon it just isn't there there's
a reservoir of trust that you need to
call upon sometimes and when the
reservoir is empty nobody's going to
trust you and i think that's so much of
what has happened with the the vaccines
is is that people who are who are not
taking the vaccine they have a real
root based level of distrust in the
public health bureaucracy in the media
to tell them the truth
because the media have not told them the
truth and i think this is true even so
far as for example risk factors and and
how exactly people differentiate based
on age and health status and they've
done polls with the american public
asking them how likely do you think you
are to die from from covet 19 broadly
and people are off by a factor of
somewhere between 10 and 100 uh and if
and if you ask people based on their age
they're off by way more than that and so
you know that that is really a problem
because what that also leads to is this
reactionary feeling like okay well if
they say if they say to do x i'm going
to do y
well
x might be right right so two things can
be true at once the public health
bureaucracy sucks and also the vaccines
are extraordinarily effective and you
should totally go get them right
like these two things are you can hold
them in your mind at the same exact time
and then when you're asked you know why
you would get the vaccine i think it's
fair to say listen i know what the ifr
is for people in my age bracket the ifr
for people in my age bracket the
infection fatality rate is higher
significantly higher than any fatality
rate that's been established for the
vaccines the prospect of me getting for
example uh myocarditis from the vaccine
is significantly actually lower from the
vaccine than it would be if i got the if
i got covid itself for my age bracket
the same may not hold true for kids
under 12 because we really don't have
any data about that and one thing that
we do know about kids under 18 is the
kids under 18 are not dying from this so
you know but the refu this comes up in
the masking context too i mean there's
an entire article in new york magazine
the other day about how there is
literally no serious evidence that mask
mandates with regard to children in
school are effective
and then you hear constantly on the news
that if you're anti-mask mandate if you
don't want to take your five-year-old
and put them in mask and send them to
school because first of all kids can't
wear masks properly they suck at it they
i mean i have three kids
seven and five and then one and the the
seven and five-year-old like they're
constantly picking at the mass taking it
off putting in their pockets spitting on
it eating putting it back right like
the cloth masks themselves are not
nearly as effective as for example in 95
you're not going to make a kid wear an
n95
and yet there's this perspective that's
cropped up that if you don't want to
mask your kid it's because you want
children to die and it's just completely
evidence-free and so people are reacting
to that by being like well screw all of
this i just screw all of it i'm not
gonna listen to anything you guys have
to say and again i think that that's the
worst of all available worlds um but
it's only the worst of all
available worlds
by a little bit because i think the
second worst of all available worlds
listen to everything have to say so
they may they may even be equivalently
dumb right that's the hard part again
and not to you know we're not we're not
doing a havarusa atomic study but uh the
point is to not go too far to the left
or to the right and they didn't mean
politically as they say uh back then i
don't think moshe robano was a was a
democrat or a republican um and by the
way thank you for using one of your
stock phrases two things can be true at
once and my household whenever ben says
that we drink two cups of wine
so thank you for for inebriating us so
early in the morning um miriam webster
the source of all scientific wisdom and
knowledge defines authoritarian as of or
relating to favoring blind submission to
authority which means in some cases that
there is an impulse there's a there's an
impulse to be a follower to be blindly
led and i wonder about that uh how again
you know this this uh this this notion
that that you know it's it's the hardest
thing to really split the difference
between um you know knowing when to obey
and knowing when to not obey but i think
their secondary definition of or
favoring concentration of power in a
leader or an elite not constitutionally
responsible to the people i think that's
almost more appropriate for this book
this book
yeah is about all the different ways the
modalities in which our lives are you
know are governed and yet again i always
have to push back with respect
uh to you my friend ben uh i've in the
last year have had on michael shermer uh
i've had on dave rubin i've had on uh
let me see on my list of past guests um
your friend your boss i think michael
knowles uh i've had on uh yeah dennis
all these people have books out and
they're all about this oppression of
free speech and and i wonder you know
how can we as or you know how can we
take uh you authors seriously those that
decry the awful suppression the the the
jack boots coming down and when you guys
are so successful and and almost making
the uh new york times bestseller list in
the case of michael knowles uh how can
we really take that seriously that that
he is surprised freedom of speech he's
left speechless what do you have to say
to critics that say come on you guys are
overdoing it so my freedom of speech has
absolutely not been suppressed now let
me make that clear from the very outset
my freedom of speech has not been
suppressed there have been sort of
attempts informally to do that right
requiring 600 police officers at
berkeley for me to speak at berkeley um
but you know my free speech listen i'm
thank god i'm we have very successful
company a lot of people listen to the
show the the problem is actually for i
think the person who's not in politics i
think and i talk about this in the book
i think that there are a lot of people
out there who are working for a
corporation that is not political
ostensibly and then they get a note from
their boss on a particular political
matter and now they're expected to
mirror the priorities of their boss and
if they don't they're going to be fired
or they're going to be held in low
esteem or you've got you know the the
you know normal american who's not in
the business of politics who post
something on facebook and all of a
sudden it blows up and their business is
being boycotted uh or you have the
normal person who's friends will talk to
them family won't talk to them anymore
because they voted for the wrong person
i mean this sort of stuff is extremely
common as far as top-down refusal to uh
allow my voice to get out there
let's put it this way there are
institutions that have attempted to
censor or there's been pressure inside
institutions to censor even me right we
saw earlier this year when i wrote the
political playbook and 200 staffers had
a phone call with the heads of politico
complaining that i was allowed to even
dismerge the sacred the sacred playbook
this actually resulted ironically in the
formation of a nascent union at politico
so i'm very eager to uh to be seen as a
union leader over at politico frankly
that's exciting i'm a labor leader now
and i'm fully happy to take credit for
the unionization of politico's workforce
but uh it sort of differs institution by
institution uh this book is not
primarily about governmental or
authoritarianism though i think that's
obviously a threat it's much more about
sort of informal social authoritarianism
uh and that i think we all do feel and
the the argument that i've heard so
often is that if it's not the government
doesn't matter and that's obviously
untrue for the vast majority of
americans for whom the institutions they
deal with most on a daily basis are not
the government right it's their it's
their it's their company it's the church
they go to it's the scientific experts
they hear on tv it's the it's the
sporting events that they consume right
all of those institutions are cramming
down a particular viewpoint
and if you refuse to acquiesce to the
viewpoint there are some pretty severe
social consequences now listen there's a
fine line between having an open and
robust debate and the attempt to for
example mobilize people against your
political opponent's business and thus
to destroy it and i think that that line
is crossed pretty frequently these days
what do you think about this reaction to
the non-governmental you know forces
that are at work uh i'm thinking in
particular of the private space flight
uh endeavors of you know bezos and
branson and musk
and how they're almost villainized uh
and i'm looking at these people and i'm
saying nasa has a budget i don't know if
you know there's been but nasa's budget
is less than what people spend on
lipstick every year now you're a
remarkably handsome man being in my uh
you know compared to me of course but uh
but that lipstick budgets you know 20
billion dollars and yet if you ask the
normal person they spend billions and
half the gdp goes to nasa no they don't
they're just remarkably successful and i
wonder you know what is this you know
reaction to the to the
non-authoritarians i i don't even know
if there's a name i'm going to get into
your neologism uh ultra crippetarianism
i can finally use that in scrabble
without embarrassment what do you make
of the hostility from robert reich my my
uh my fellow colleague at that fine
institution up north uc berkeley what
what do you make of this this
vilification almost of ways to save the
government money i mean they've reduced
the cost of private space flight and of
commercial space flight by order of
magnitude why are people so resistant to
efforts to to save the government money
i mean well i mean frankly i don't think
it has anything to do with saving the
government money i think they could
spend their money on literally anything
and they would still be decried for
their wealth unless they you know sign a
payout to a particular approved
organization
what they're really angry at is that
jeff bezos is rich i mean if jeff bases
were not rich they wouldn't be angry at
him it has nothing to do with what he
does with his own money and frankly i
think that it's very cool both that he
is very wealthy and that he used that
money to do something really awesome in
developing new technologies that human
beings haven't been able to develop
before that's a that's a pretty amazing
thing same thing with elon musk i am i'm
utterly confused why people are upset
about this except that i think there's a
root jealousy that has been inculcated
by a political elite that says that if
somebody is worth quote unquote too much
money this means anything they do from
here on out is bad they were good people
until they made a lot of money then they
made a lot of money and they became bad
and i think this has infected frankly
the whole society i think that there's i
mean if you go back to the 1930s
there there was a feeling about people
who were wealthy which is
that
i would also like to be one of them
which is why people i mean if you look
at the lines like the bread lines during
the great depression right a horrifying
time in american history economically
people on the red line is wearing suits
and there's suits and hats and ties in
the bread line and now you have
billionaires who are attempting to dress
like homeless people because what you
aspire to be today is a person who does
not take stock of their wealth right if
you if you're really cool with the
people then you can never show that
you're wealthy listen honestly one of
the things there are many things i found
not charming about trump one of the
things that i found absolutely charming
about trump is that he was like yeah i'm
rich so
i am
yes good i mean like really we need more
of that because i would like more people
to be rich i'd like more people to
openly aspire to that and it's funny
honestly there are parts of american
culture where this actually is not
rejected right for example rap culture
really glorifies making a lot of money i
don't think that's a bad thing i've been
making a lot of money if you're engaging
in a bunch of consensual transactions
with others and then you are saying i
made a lot of money and i hope you do do
i don't see anything wrong with that i
think that's a perfectly good thing but
there's this sort of embarrassment that
american society now inculcates about
success that is really antithetical to
to encouraging people to pursue that
success there's this notion that jeff
bezos is quote unquote the privilege if
you look at jeff bezos's life story that
dude did not grow up privileged right
right if you if you look at steve jobs
life story these are people who did not
grow up you know in the heart of luxury
they made something of themselves and
yes of course they had people who helped
them because we all have people who help
us along our way no question and we
should all seek to help others along
their way but this this kind of stark
divide between how we call people who
are wealthy the privilege versus the
quote unquote underprivileged it seems
to me that that we actually have to
define what the privilege is before we
determine whether somebody is privileged
or underprivileged
right and then the notion you know it
smacks against the notion of gratitude
or hakarsatov as we say um and i think
that's dangerous you know this notion
that if everybody's we level by the way
they never like talk about how much
lebron james makes in a day right
it's always jeff bezos and richard
branson and elon musk it's i don't know
why but but for anyway they're always
you know they're always famous you know
saying you know who cares if it works in
in practice does it work in theory you
know that's the question we should have
would you go to space ben if they had
glot tang
um i would go to space regardless of
whether they had glot tang i mean like
the space is is awesome i've been trying
to convince my wife that one once it
gets safe enough yeah um where i where
you know there's not a one in 10 chance
of the thing blowing pretty much
then once that happens i'm totally up
for it i mean there are there are a
couple developments i'm really up i'm up
for that i'm really up for a lot of the
talk about how this is going to lower
travel time
i just think it'd be unbelievable to be
able to fly from like florida to
australia and take an hour and a half
that would be unbelievable yeah and you
get to finally get a good night's sleep
when you're on the road uh you'd lose a
sponsor though i don't think you know
your mattress company will support a
zero gravity mattress um i want to ask a
question about uh another i'm gonna read
another definition from miriam webster
merriam-webster uh dictionary it's ultra
crepitarianism and the definition is
this word does not exist uh did you make
this word up then because i had never
heard it before you and i i'm uh i'm a
master of the mojust uh what is ultra
crepitarianism and and am i guilty of it
i i start to think i might be guilty of
this malady i mean i think that that all
of us are guilty of it a little bit but
ultra crepitarianism is the idea that
you are speaking outside of your area of
expertise and i just thought there
really ought to be a german term for it
but there really isn't so we'll just
have to use the the english ultra
crepitarian ultra crepitarian is a is a
word i call it the uh i call it almost a
philosophy ultra crucitarianism um but
the the it's a phenomenon for sure uh
that and this i discussed in sort of the
purview of science is that you have this
vast attempt in the in the field of
science for people to speak out of areas
that they actually know anything about
uh and you saw this largely in the
public health debate right over the last
year where suddenly we moved from you
know what are disease vectors and how do
they work and what are the
epidemiol epidemiological studies saying
to
if you protest for george floyd you
definitely won't get the virus and it
was like and this and racism is a public
health problem i said well if you're
defining racism as a public health
problem then we're not talking about
public health anymore right we're just
we're not you talk about racism as a
problem but talking about it as a public
health problem broadly speaking is now
saying that everything is a public
health problem which i think is sort of
the point once you start it has a couple
of effects one is that you have a bunch
of people talking about stuff they don't
know about and the second is that when
you broaden your field out to include
everything people start to seeing start
seeing their own perspective as part of
your field you'll start to see people
saying unscientific things and then say
those things in the name of science even
though they're not sciences right the
science says x and x is just a political
view that i happen to hold okay well
maybe not maybe science doesn't say that
and also when you cite a scientist the
scientist has to be talking about like
you are in the sciences i i don't think
that means that you are an excellent
cook right now you could theoretically
broaden out the possibilities of science
to include you know how the chemistry of
cooking works and you could probably
talk about that all day long but i'm not
going to assume that you know how to
cook an egg because you're a scientist
and yet because science is the most
valuable institution that we have in
terms of just pure human prosperity
there there is this willingness to grant
a halo effect to science where we're
like okay well the scientists said it
and dude's wearing a white coat i guess
i'll just do what he says now even
though it makes no sense at all
well yeah on this frame i did a video
called follow the science which i argue
just that that you should not you know
for prager university that you shouldn't
you know this this notion that that you
know because someone has a phd in
chemistry and i pointed out you know
fritz haber who is the father of uh of a
fertilizer that powered our breakfast
food this morning he also invented
chemical weapons and he won the nobel
prize in chemistry after world war one
when these weapons were used and he
personally witnessed the the devastation
that they wrought so listening to him on
social policy or even warfare is a
tragic mistake and as i quote you know
in the in that video richard feynman
said science is actually the belief in
the ignorance of experts not the wisdom
of experts you know the word science as
i pointed out to your uh friend michael
knowles it doesn't mean wisdom it means
knowledge and wisdom is knowing not to
you know knowledge is knowing a tomato
is a fruit and wisdom is knowing not to
put it in a fruit salad
but i wonder you know as galileo said um
in the sciences the authority of
thousands of opinions is not worth as
much once as one spark of reason from an
individual man and i wonder
you know the book about authoritarianism
um when we look to science is there a
danger in kind of venerating science too
much in the sense that scientists have
all the traits i always say scientists
are like children you know they're
curious they're they're whimsical
they're they're intellectual you know
they they just want to know everything
they're passionate they don't play well
with others they don't share their toys
they're jealous they're petty
we have a lot of negative traits in
science doesn't mean don't listen to
science i'm not antagonistic obviously
i've devoted my life to it um but what
is there not a danger we do have
authority bias we have prestige bias we
have confirmation we have all these
biases in not the science tm
ben shapiro 2021 uh but uh in science
itself we have all these biases
prejudices lacunae in our character why
why should we venerate science so much
yeah i mean i think that this is why you
know venerating science as a process
that is capable of producing useful
results to people is totally worthwhile
but even that you know has its limits
meaning that
i feel like people do the same thing
with economics they'll say well
economics doesn't fill the the needs of
the human soul and i keep thinking
myself right did ever say it was going
to like well
why would it uh and and it's the same
thing with science except that a lot of
scientists think that science is
supposed to fill the need in the human
soul right this is my kind of
long-running debate with sam harris i
don't think that you can get from is to
ought i don't think that you can look at
the scientific facts of of existence and
then immediately go from there to a
cohesive moral framework that wasn't
actually kind of rooted in just
judeo-christian morals that you're now
guising as humanism so it's you know i i
think that there's a real mistake that
is made by by folks uh in science to
declare that everything is science and
also by people who are not scientific to
simply grant credibility to that because
once you slap the label science on
something we're all supposed to believe
it and there's also this this bizarre
and stupid reductionism where people
will give very complex results but then
they think that the public can't handle
the results and so they reduce it down
to some sort of headline that actually
isn't true right you see this all the
time in science you see it you see it
you saw with covert a lot um but you
certainly see it with global warming as
well right where where they will say
people will say global warming is a is a
threat to
how we live over the course of the next
century that's a very broad statement
it's a very broad statement then you get
into the specifics and you look at it
you say okay well it's probably going to
lead to for example more intense
hurricanes but it doesn't necessarily
have a an impact on frequency of
hurricanes and it's unclear if the
damage done by hurricanes is actually
due to the increased winds of the
hurricane or the fact that the target
has now increased because people are
building more on these guys right and
when you look at you know the even the
impact of global warming over the course
of time the ipcc itself has a very like
a rather broad range of how much the
temperature could change over the course
of the next century it's like anywhere
from 1.5 degrees celsius to 4.5 degrees
celsius which is a huge range and when
you point out all of this or when you
point out that that certain solutions
that are undertaken in the name of
science are very unlikely to to have
any sort of serious effect on the
climate say the kyoto protocols or the
paris peace accords when you point that
out then people say you're anti-science
and it's like well no i'm using the
exact same source as you are i'm just
making a different political argument
but this is now considered anti-science
on the basis of what exactly and you
know that that's that's a dangerous
thing because then again you get we are
getting to the point very quickly where
when institutions are misused people
lose trust in the institution if you
lose trust in science as as a value then
that's going to have some really dire
downstream effects uh frankly i think
that you're seeing it for a lot of folks
who refuse to take the vaccine not for
any scientific reason but just because
they just don't trust the institutions
promulgating
the sort of science talk that isn't
really scientifically rooted right you
see that a lot every i joke in my book
uh you know every four years we find out
from 17 nobel prize
prize winners you know which which you
know democrat we should vote for
and uh you know it becomes you know what
is someone who studies low temperature
super conductivity or string theory yeah
what do they have to teach us about uh
you know who should be the you know the
leader of the free world the most
powerful country in human history i want
to talk about big tech now obviously
you're no you know you're a huge fan of
technology uh you uh you know you can
eat like a king nowadays you can live
better than a kid you can get a
chauffeur to come to your house with a
push of a button you can get a
home-cooked meal uh you know from from
your favorite you know place down the
street delivered to you from your mother
or you can get a restaurant cooked meal
if you're so inclined uh you can get
medical diagnoses uh i believe you met
your wife on tinder uh these are all
social media and other you know tools to
community you have more reach than you
know almost anybody on earth i had neil
degrasse tyson on my show a couple
months back and i said neil you're the
most famous scientist in human history
because you know 40 million people know
who you are right now and you can you
know it's not like you're you're you're
you know you've passed away and he's
like no no but the influence that
technology confers is this double-edged
sword as the bible says is this worth it
is the is this tool because it seems to
me you know twitter is the most
efficient tool ever devised for
spreading la shanhara you know evil
speech uh how do we how do we balance
the technology authority that is
inherent in all these apps because we
love it we need this technology and we
live better because of it how do you
balance those two competing demands
for sure and and i think that that's
particularly true with a lot of these
services that are really designed to be
kind of addictive i mean the fact is
that when they design twitter for
example that little kind of flip that
you hear every time you refresh is
designed to be almost a pavlovian
response for you that you get like a
little dopamine hit every time you do
that yeah um and that's why you find
yourself doing it all the time and so
for me i just took twitter directly off
my phone right if i want to be on
twitter i'm going to have to be on my
computer and sit and think about what
i'm typing as opposed to just being on
my phone and just randomly throwing
things out there which has been i think
beneficial for my life and the answer to
this is like the answer to you know all
other problems of technological systems
that both make our lives better but also
provide for the possibility of greater
sin and that is you really have to
create prophylactic rules for yourself
in their ears and this has been true
about literally every technology ever
developed right or pretty much all of
them uh that if you are like the the car
made possible the ability to have an
affair in another city right like if
you're if you're if you're horse bound
basically the group of people that you
could go out with and sleep with was
limited to the distance that you could
take your horse within a couple of hours
yeah it wasn't all that dark genghis
khan it really wasn't bad for him the
horn right well yeah he he made a yeah
he had unique success in this respect
but but the but the car and and the
plane right all of these things enable
sin in ways that the horse does not you
know does that mean that the car and the
plane are bad no of course the car and
the planer are wonderful wonderful
creations
what it does mean is that
as a species we have tended to confuse
this goes back to your last question a
little bit we have tended to confuse
technological and scientific development
with moral development and they are not
the same thing whatsoever and in fact as
technology gets more sophisticated
there is a significant call on the human
capacity to be more moral and we have
largely shirked the call we have insane
levels while we talk about the level of
privacy that's not uh available online
and you should all get express vpn for
this the reality is that you can now
partake in all sorts of sin from the
privacy of your own home that you would
have to go out into public to do before
and so this is enabled sin on record
levels so this means that you actually
have to be prophylactic in your own
acknowledgment of your own sinful
capacity and yet we also live in a
society that says that to even mention
the capacity for sin is to be shaming
people they don't want to sin shame
somebody you don't want to make somebody
feel bad about themselves and so you
know with greater technology comes a
greater need for for us to be reflective
about how we act
and that's difficult i mean nobody likes
being reflective it's no fun except for
me and yom kippur that's the thing
that's right you're fasting your yom
kippur app has saved many it actually
allowed me to drop five pounds uh from
my double chin to my backside um i want
to ask now about another thing near and
dear to my heart and i know your heart
too in all seriousness academia uh
you're a scholar you clearly uh you know
thoroughly love the life of the mind and
and on one hand you know academia hasn't
really changed much in a thousand years
since the first university in bologna
italy in 1080 you have you know some guy
scratching on a piece of rock with
another piece of rock and and we call
that learning and almost nothing has
changed in that millennium uh since um i
wonder you know our are is there
something in store you know you've got
this media corporation now you've got uh
you're now doing entertainment you've
obviously been doing news i wonder if
the by the way is daily wire planning
like a national the science foundation
with academia
do you see it ripe for disruption do you
see this you know as you talk about in
the book you talk about the um the uh
what the the varsity blues scandal you
know we had these actresses and actors
getting their daughters into college
that didn't want to go to college and
didn't even need to take the sat for the
co they want to go to juilliard one of
them you know she didn't even need to go
take the sats let alone be coached
illicitly in doing so so anyway what do
you see as the uh opportunities for
disruption in academia which you spend
not an inconsiderable amount of time in
the book uh devoting to
so this is one place where i think the
internet's really going to help so first
of all you see a tremendous appetite for
people who do want to learn online right
you have things like the great courses
plus
or hillsdale online programs and people
or prager you for that matter
people who are looking for information
on a regular basis uh and and want it
and i think that as more and more
colleges move online i think the
pandemic helps accelerate this i think
that you're gonna see alternatives start
to form that are a hell of a lot cheaper
than hundreds of thousands of dollars a
year in order to effectuate that you're
going to need businesses to stop looking
at the ivy league credential as though
it is the bl end all and this is coming
from somebody who went to an ivy league
law school i i don't actually think that
that is necessary for somebody to even
go to college in order to be an
excellent employee and i think there
will come a point where smart first
movers in the space are going to start
seeking
good employees in places outside sort of
the traditional
well-trod paths right there there's
gonna be somebody who instead decided to
get their degree in something in a year
and a half being an online program by a
harvard extension or something and then
people look at that and go well that's
good enough for me they also got a 1500
on their sat so i know they're smart and
i think that colleges unless you're in
the actual hard sciences i think that
colleges have largely become uh a
sorting mechanism and and the sorting
mechanism is a very expensive sorting
mechanism that puts people severely into
debt but i don't think that just because
you got a polyside agree from ucla the
way that i did i don't think that means
that you're necessarily going to be a
better employee than a person who got
the same score i did on the sat
graduated the same age and didn't get a
polished degree from ucla
i wonder though i mean i'm actually
working on a project to take the written
word of galileo for the first time and
make it into an artificial intelligent
learning engine
because there's never been something
like that and why learn you know
celestial mechanics for me when you can
learn it from isaac newton or galileo
as good as i think i am at teaching it
but then it opens up to me this concern
that you know with machine learning and
artificial intelligence do you see you
know kind of a
you know a very brief calm before that
storm when now it's going to be if you
thought it was at scale before the
spying the the authoritarianism once we
get you know super computers quantum
computers uh in charge of the algorithms
are we just toast
um i mean we may very well be but again
i think that as with
as i was saying with all technology
comes you know you we have to have a lot
of humility when we approach these
technologies uh and and recognize that
we're going to have to set limits on
ourselves because uh you know when it
comes to the the vagaries of machine
learning you know better than i do uh so
i i'm i'm not you know i tend to be sort
of a technological optimist as opposed
to you know somebody who believes that
skynet is coming and it's going to kill
all of us and that the the machines are
going to wake up and decide that uh
we're their overlords and it's time to
kill everyone if that happens then i
guess i'll you know just be among the
ruins and won't have much to say about
it um but but as long as that doesn't
happen then the increased capacity seems
to me to open a lot of vistas for people
but you know there are there are
consummate downsides obviously in how
this stuff is used we're going to need a
lot better controls
governmental or otherwise although i
don't trust the government to control
itself in these areas right and building
on that and technology uh as a whole uh
i think i was uh uh able to connect you
with michael saylor who's one of the
biggest uh bitcoin proponents on the on
the face of the planet and i was glad to
make that connection uh but i want to
talk about disruption there because we
saw recently um you know and my
condolence has been that they took down
your favorite site only fans uh where
you have
you know one of the most popular
accounts in uh in yiddish kite um
wearing tuxedos that's all it is
it's you and stylized kipa
uh that's the only way you can get it is
join ben's only fans account but anyway
they took it down right and those are
credit cards and we had amazon web
services take down you know parlor and
so forth um do you see opportunities i
don't know if you got into this with
michael uh sailor but uh i know many of
my audience is very curious about what
can things like the
decentralization of technology the
authoritarianism of both blockchain and
bitcoin as a means of transaction that's
immune from government you know snooping
in some level i'm not going to get into
the details but but also for things like
academia and even communication uh
peer-to-peer not relying on you know
twitter could turn off your account
tomorrow as we know right so what do you
see are you optimistic about that are
there any potentials that that you're
most interested in in that space isn't
technical i mean i'm super pumped up
about that so the the decentralization
of of money you know via bitcoin uh the
the effectuation of that technology and
other spheres and decentralization of
informational dissemination right which
has sort of been done but on the old
mechanisms just like money used to be
done on the old mechanisms right what
paypal was instead the sort of next
generation stuff where it will be
completely peer-to-peer and you won't
need an intermediary to do any of that
uh everything will just sort of live
in the ether and be verified not by a
centralized company saying that you are
you but by a blockchain technology for
example like that stuff's gonna be
really cool and it's also going to allow
for a lot to thrive now that also is
going to mean that bad guys thrive but
you know that that is just the risk of
liberty is that bad people do bad things
and and that's a risk that i'm willing
to take i think that the attempt over
and over and over again for example to
cast the bad people out from facebook
has not resulted in the bad people not
being online it's resulted in them being
at 4chan and then a chan and then
presumably 16 chan and they'll just keep
chanting it up and and at a certain
point you know they go underground and
they go to places where and the
government follows them and all of that
you know maybe that's effective maybe
that's not but but it seems to me that
the greater risk to me is a centralized
authority telling you what you can and
cannot say online for example or what
financial transactions you can and
cannot pursue right if credit card
companies i think in the near future
might be in the position where they just
start banning particular credit card
users because they don't like who they
are there was a report over the weekend
that maybe one of the credit card
companies was doing that to michael
flynn you know that scares the living
hell out of me like these are neutral
service providers and so the potential
to you know just have a bitcoin wallet
for example where
it's not up to bitcoin it's not up to
coinbase to decide if you can and cannot
have a wallet and i mean frankly they
can't they they don't even have the
capacity to determine you know whose
wallet it is really um because you know
theoretically if you're if you've got
you know bitcoin in the name of a code
then the code owns the wallet if that's
if that's the case then it removes a lot
of these obstacles i'm very much in
favor of i've been thinking a lot about
this since i got kind of in a bitcoin
over the last couple of months three
months
and i'm very into the idea of radical
decentralization at this point because
we've seen radical centralization in
corporate life we've seen radical
centralization in informational
dissemination we've seen radical
dissemination in terms of money supply
and so if we can reverse a lot of those
trends i think that'd be an excellent
thing
and in terms of that you know the media
outreach etc uh i do think that there's
incredible opportunities for this
technology and even in science i think
you could do things where you could um
you know somebody has some discovery or
some you know vaccine but they don't
they're not ready for it to be released
they could stake it on the blockchain
show proof of work and uh and and and
you know and this could be something
that could transform science as well i
think we're yeah we're definitely in the
early days there and uh and and i'm
excited to see what happens there
speaking of you know going in into the
you know the realm of of media that you
are so uh so expert in
there's a famous yiddish saying i'm sure
you've heard it um you know he who
stands in the middle of the road gets
hit by both sides of the traffic in
other words uh the fact that you are so
um
courageous you know some say brazen uh
do you take more risks now would you say
ben as your you know as your celebrity
increases the network effect you know
you have
this wide-ranging influence now that you
you know probably couldn't have dreamed
of just 10 years ago when i first
started following you um you know do you
think that there's uh that there's a
limit or that there's you know some some
restraint on who you are that will you
know allows you to take risks that maybe
some of the readers couldn't you know if
one of my students you know writes me
and says you know i i can't say this to
my professor in class but you know maybe
i can say it to you i get messages like
that all the time um you know he or she
could get could get uh repercussions uh
and and yet you you you know make your
living on having an opinion and being
paid to do so quite handsomely as we
know from expressvpn uh but i don't know
like um have you become more bold or
have you decided to just take more more
chances now or are you still the same
old ben you know that i listened to on
uh what was it truth revolt a decade ago
yeah i mean i think there's there's some
both so on the one hand i'm more
prominent that means i can withstand
more risk so that's that's great it
means i can say things that you know i
can get away with things that maybe
other people can't like i'm if i have
strong feelings about vaccines i'm going
to say what the strong feelings about
vaccines are and if it takes people off
then you know so be it i try to i try to
couch everything i say in terms of data
so if people want to get mad at the data
i'm using that's okay um but you know i
i've always tried to approach things
from a data-driven point of view except
when maybe i was 17 or 18 and you're
just you know attention-seeking which is
what people do when they're teenagers
unfortunately when you're 17 or 18 are
writing a public column the attention
seeking is on your permanent record so
in any case uh it's it's not quite you
know now obviously i'm able to say
things that i think many other people
aren't able to say uh on politics and
networks in both directions although for
you know for a lot of people i'd say
it's mostly from the right uh the the
you know counter intuitive effect is
that if you are you know very prominent
and if you speak to a lot of people this
means that if you make a mistake
everybody notices right and so this
means that you have to be very very
careful in how you approach this stuff
and that's the stuff of nightmares right
you know like i literally will have
nightmares where i get on the air and i
say sing say something that's just
totally untrue
and i'll wake up in a cold sweat like oh
god i hope i didn't say that and it's
you know and that i try to be extremely
careful about what i see on there at
least factually speaking you know when
it comes to opinion you get impassioned
you say things you fly off the cuff that
sort of stuff happens but you know you
you really do have to be careful in this
sort of information you disseminate and
even in your approach right there's
certain sort of there there is a an
overton window i think the overton
window right now in american life is far
too narrow but it does exist right and
uh and you know seeking to say the right
thing uh while not triggering for
example the overlords at youtube to to
take you down uh is is always sort of an
interesting balance that you have to
draw because you know people might might
say that that's self-interested well you
know if nobody can actually hear my show
it's not just self-interested it's
listener interested right listeners
still want to hear the show
and along those lines that because it's
the eve of yom kippur
um i want to ask you about you know the
we talk about sin and sinning at scale
with the rise of technology uh what
about teshuva what about repentance what
about atonement um are there
opportunities can we get tone for
anything i mean uh is there is a room
not just in the overton window which i
think of as you know is kind of remote
for most of my listeners but you know
they're not on cnn or in the new york
times which who published one of your uh
your obituary uh eulogizing rush
limbaugh i mean i thought that was a
very positive sign um but anyway is
there room for teshuva or you know
repentance or is it is it cast in the
amber of the blockchain of of
cancellation and recrimination
uh so i think it depends from whom so
there's a certain group of people whose
sole goal in life is just to extirpate
you from public life and for those
people there's no repentance but i think
for most other people there there really
is and i think americans generally want
to give people second chances and allow
them back through the door i think that
there's been an attempt right now to
basically say that whatever sins you've
committed are
on your permanent record you can never
come back from that and i'm actively
trying to fight back against that right
i mean like
i think that if you said something that
was bad and now you want to and now
you've repented and now you want to come
back to public life i think that we
should try to make some pretty
significant efforts to allow that to
happen because we ought to incentivize
teshuva i've done some of that stuff
publicly myself right i mean i'm the
only columnist i know of i think ever
who has put up like an entire list of
the things i think i've said over the
course of the last 20 years that i think
are wrong or bad and then try to explain
what i was trying to say or what i
failed to say or whether i was just
being an idiot right no i gave media
matters a kill list that that was
actually
yeah i mean that's what it was i mean i
effectively went back through and i was
like okay here's all the stuff that i've
said over the last 20 years here's a
really bad tweet here's what i meant by
it it didn't come out that way and it's
bad and i think that that's a useful
thing i think we should all you know do
that from time to time there been times
when i've done this interpersonally i
remember that you know way back when
like when i was a kid maybe 17 18 years
old i tweeted something that wasn't
particularly nice about uh rabbi david
wolpe in los angeles
and i got and barry weiss who i was
friends with she said you know you don't
know rabbi walpi and you really should
like meet with him and i called him up
and uh we got together and he explained
he expressed to me how upset he'd been
by that tweet and i was like yeah that
was you know at that point 15 years ago
and i didn't realize that you know that
i was young and stupid and i'm i'm sorry
about that he said right but it's one
thing for you to apologize to me in
person and you know that tweet is still
out there and so i went on twitter and i
put out a tweet saying you know
sometimes you just get people wrong and
you get things wrong and i apologize for
this that was wrong it was like 10 15
years later so i think that you know
apologizing at scale is very often
effective and and uh you know you as
donald trump says you try to be in a
position where you don't have to
apologize but uh if you do then it does
give you the opportunity to do so uh in
in pretty large measure and uh every
donald trump or john kerry impersonation
by ben earns somebody a glass of whiskey
in my house thank you ben for that um
speak yeah there is the famous muscle
story of a man who disparages his rabbi
and then goes and asks for repentance
and forgiveness and the rabbi says yeah
bring a pillow and the guy says all
right i'll bring a feather pillow what's
it for a guy cut his rabbi says cut it
open let the wind scatter the feathers
to the four winds and the guy says oh
thank you rabbi for forgiving me he said
no you're not forgiven yet now go out
and collect all the feathers and i think
that's really true it is harder to you
know put the toothpaste back in the tube
as as they say then and then to squeeze
it out in the first place the lightning
round has has uh come upon us ben i know
you only have five minutes left so i
want to play the lightning round of into
the impossible as we are want to do on
this podcast uh reminder we're speaking
to ben shapiro a proprietor of the ben
shapiro show the sunday special which
i've been honored to be a part of and i
i know i apologize in advance to all the
all the many only fans that i'm going to
lose but uh but you know what i i love
talking to ben i learn something every
time i talk every time you write a book
i'm glad i can see your hands so i know
you're not actually writing your 18th
book in three years
but i look forward to all your future
work um is there anyone that you
wouldn't talk to on the show i mean not
just like a farrah can or somebody like
a repugnant uh invidious you know human
being but um is there anyone you
wouldn't talk to that's kind of in the
public sphere or conversely is there
someone you're dying to talk to uh you
know and you just can't get for one
reason or another
uh so i mean there's some people who
i've tried to get on the program who i
think would be really interesting to
talk to like i think it'd be interesting
to talk to george w bush uh we haven't
had that opportunity yet um there's some
uh you know kind of more obscure
professors who wouldn't be obscure in
their fields but our obscure kind of the
general public who i think would be fun
to talk to um to sort of
and you have to sort of monetize it and
figure out how that works right because
a fun conversation doesn't always mean
that it pays for itself in terms of crew
time or anything um so
that's that's as far as people who i
wouldn't talk to uh outside of an affair
outside of you know the fair con crowd
and you know people who i like because
you're talking publicly one of the
things that you do have to determine is
whether you believe that the view is so
vile that
that airing the view itself uh is doing
a disservice because no matter how well
you're about the position you've now
granted the position added credibility
uh and i don't believe that there's no
such thing as the overton window i i
make a pretty strong distinction between
the presence of an overton window which
i agree with and the limits of the
overton window which i think right now
are far too too narrow uh but yeah i
mean there are people who i think it's
worthless to talk to where i'd be
radically raising somebody's profile uh
to no purpose other than to radically
raise the profile of a terrible person
or a person who i think has terrible
beliefs and obviously like i wouldn't
have on the spokesperson for the taliban
to give their point of view on on
women's rights
you can just go to their twitter account
that's true that's true you can go to
their twitter account uh so there's some
of that and then there are some people
who uh you know i just don't think are
up for a real conversation and who are
just there to uh to score points
and
you know well there might be an
organized debate setting where that
might be useful right where you say okay
well this is gonna be you know rock and
soccer robots we know the rules going in
uh but what you don't like and what i
don't like is you organize a
conversation and then the person comes
in treating it like a boxing match it's
like well that's that's not right yeah
and so you sort of have to set the
preconditions on the ground for what the
conversation is going to look like and
then if somebody breaks the rules then
you have to you have to smack them yeah
yeah i believe debate is basically
pointless you never commit oh that was a
great biden trump debate that really
changed my mind um how do you know when
you're doing a good interview how do you
know when an interview is going well uh
you know what what's running what's the
algorithm in the back your mind in real
time feedback to know that you're doing
a good job or not
i mean usually it kind of comes down
level of engagement so a bad interview
is is one where i'm getting tired or
bored and so my speed of speaking or
thinking starts to slow down i start to
get distracted i have to re-ask the
interviewer what the question was
you know that sort of stuff um as far as
sort of an adversarial interview um it i
if i take on i've realized that the more
passionate i am about topics sometimes
the worse i am at them uh you know a
certain level of reserve is necessary in
the same way that you know a doctor
wouldn't want to operate on a relative i
don't ask my wife to operate on our kids
god forbid um you know she's if you're
too invested in something you tend to
lose the necessary objectivity to having
a productive conversation and so uh when
you get to a certain level of remove
that's actually sometimes quite good for
a conversation especially if the
discussion is adversarial if you're too
invested you can get over the top and
i've had conversations like that
publicly that i regret and things sucked
yeah
uh last question in the zeitgeist
literally are these uh notions of ufos
unidentified flying objects you haven't
had any real uh discussion of that on
your show i'm wondering why do you think
it's so much in the zeitgeist in the
spirit of the times and what what do we
make of uh you know its importance and
and threat perhaps to this country uh do
you think that aliens exist do you think
they're among us do you think that uh
there's reason to be suspicious where
where do you come down on that uh so i
think aliens may exist i do not think
they are among us unless we're talking
about like
animal species because those are weird
um
and uh and do i think that they are like
you know foreign objects uh from china
or something i don't think they have
that sort of tech capacity at this point
if they do i think that we'll be the
first to know um so i i'm really really
skeptical of all ufo talk especially
have you ever seen one of my favorite
things is the map of ufo settings um so
if you look at the map of ufo settings
basically the entire united states is
lit up and then the rest of the world
there's nothing right it's like why is
that it's either because the aliens are
specifically and only interested in the
american way of life uh and like the
simpsons or because americans are
uniquely susceptible to looking up in
the sky seeing things with lights on and
being like i don't recognize that thing
with light on i'm gonna take a picture
of it and i'm gonna tell people that it
was a ufo so i don't know i'm really
really skeptical of of the
it's alien intelligences and they're
they're hanging out but they're also not
doing anything and they have to monitor
us using physical objects as opposed to
you know surveillance craft from space
or anything like that i'm i count myself
among the wild skeptics of this stuff
yeah yeah and hopefully you know if they
do decide to serve you they'll they'll
you know at least fatten you up with
some good kosher meal beforehand uh ben
shapiro uh a long time uh listener uh
second time host of you on the into the
impossible podcast i wanna thank you i
wanna wish you an easy fast i wanna wish
you new year's blessings uh to you and
your family of health and success and i
just uh wanna keep uh giving you uh the
hope that you will continue in this
courageous uh stance that you take in
society i think you are uh an extremely
important figure in in the culture and
uh and in our world so thank you then
for being on my guest and thanks so much
good morning
bye ben
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
if you hated this video i know you'll
love this interview with ben's former
harvard law professor larry tribe and if
you did enjoy this video please check
out my past interview with ben shapiro
here and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]